Humanity has always hunted for knowledge
in the unknown
the Wonder is
not that the field of stars is so vast
that we have measured it
[Music]
thank you
we're all here because we're committed
to the biggest question of all what's
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
we do not fully understand all that is
at work here no final group in the stars
to be unraveling this mystery
here on out to Captain grab jump is
ready I love this park
these artifacts could be everything
we've been looking for another great
secret the universe is asking us to
unravel
settlement throughout the Galaxy could
be at risk
we are not stopping whatever lies at the
end of this road
we'll change Humanity
forever
This Is Where We Belong
[Music]
[Applause]
oh we're finally doing this are we
because I was going to make a sandwich
okay
let's do it
[Music]
what do I think about heroes
well we've all seen them haven't we
swatting about the place
with their disproportionately high cheek
bones and comically massive weapons
roughing up Bandits because they like to
rough up Bandits don't they living it up
with the common folk every single night
on a day-to-day basis I'll say the true
heroes me someone who's breaking you
ground with fruit with veg on the
agricultural side of things
not wafting around mythical creatures
and that's what they are wafters yeah
well done you see I'm not here to slay
legendary beasts I'm here to conquer the
vegetable not a euphemism let's face it
the age of Heroes is over this is the
age of innovation this if you will is
the age of death
one moment
oh
this is awkward
yeah
[Music]
thank you
ah
she can feel them
slipping through her soul
following the threads of her mind
she's here to find them
yeah one too high
she needs her help with a promise
when it's never so simple is it
has a prize
there's always a part of you that
changes
a part of you that darkens
and a part of you that dies over there
about to pull
I can feel them feel them everywhere The
Lost Ones they are watching us
come here
I can I can see us
what is going to happen it's time to
find out how can we make it happen it's
time to find out why
it's time to find out what are they
waiting for
what are you waiting for I'm here
[Music]
watching more than one
I know
where are they where are you what do
they want
their eyes everywhere can feel them
boring into her which what is she
supposed to do do something awesome what
do you want me to do
[Music]
well to find us
are you ready for what you'll find here
what if it's all for nothing
what is that
they are waiting
to do to us
[Music]
be parts of here that are broken you can
all the grief all the rage
[Music]
let me choose this place
we get lost forever
what will happen to them what will
happen to you
I will not let them down she is ready
they know go
[Music]
who are these around you sir
those you have saved
for those you've led to death
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
at least that's what I hear
the empire
[Music]
they're everywhere
but the world here
belongs to syndicates
[Music]
I want to survive
I have to play their game
looks like I'm all in
no no she's in here somewhere one second
thought I'm out
[Music]
there she is
I've been held back my whole life
and now
I just need a chance to finally be free
wherever that takes me
I'm here to offer you a way out okay
get off my ship Jalen
chance
to trust me it'll be dangerous risky but
if you pull this off you'll never look
over your shoulder again
[Music]
the underworld shows no mercy
it's a big Galaxy out there
risk it off
[Music]
laughs
Star Wars Outlaws coming 2024
[Applause]
[Music]
not strong enough
thank you
welcome to the scum bar the most
notorious Tavern on melee Island
wall-to-wall Rogues and Scoundrels
so tell me which ship is right for you A
big ship a luxury ship a ship with just
a splash of je ne sais quoi the legend
of Monkey Island you mean Governor guy
brush but freeport's not set foot out of
that Mansion for almost a year hey what
do you think you're doing I told you no
autographs
so I see you have a meet and greet
ticket and I guess it's not every day
that you get to meet the mighty pirate
guy Rush Street wood the legend of
Monkey Island
the Chuck has turned the memories of
this island into a prison for guybrush
well well what do we have here
you need these
things may be very different from the
sea of Thieves you know
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign guys it's a simple job
we're standing out nothing to it
[Music]
everybody hit the floor
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
Appalachia what a sight a verdant
Wonderland of Promise pluck from
post-atomic flight the fruit of years of
prudent progress and determined
Reclamation and 15 million dwellers
worth of keen imagination from the heart
of West Virginia to the depths of the
pits
[Music]
no matter if you roam alone or spend
your time with friends you'll find a
home in Appalachia where the good times
never end there are relics to uncover
from a time before the war along with
loads of friendly folks to meet and
enemies Galore our world is always
changing greater puzzles are overthrown
as we embark on Expeditions into
thrilling new unknowns yes from
Appalachian settlements to Nuka World on
tour you're never short on things to do
or places to explore I think you've seen
it all
well how about this pack your bags for
an escape of Epicurean Bliss put your
rad shield on and fix your hair up
pretty because we're headed for the
boardwalk of Atlantic City
so there you have it now you know
there's a million ways to make the
Wasteland your waste home and when you
hear Adventure calling when you're
looking for some kicks answer the call
answer
the call of all 76
play it now with Xbox game pass
I know you're ready you've got this
oh
let's tweak the car's performance for
the next one
[Music]
foreign
play it day one with Game Pass
I have seen all that ever was and all
that ever will be
I have seen betrayal
endurance
ambition
courage
I am the one who knows
foreign
[Music]
a secret that threatens to unravel
reality it's self
[Music]
Tamriel
foreign
[Music]
Toronto is under attack
through no sector
something
about no sector this time
they've taken over most of the city and
the rounding up omnics they need our
help
people are answering Vincent's recalls
his new blood on the team and we have so
much to teach them
maybe we can save the city coming
through
it's been a while as if I didn't have
enough problems already
so we play up there smash through
anything that gets in our way
and what's another business I hate to
interrupt the moment but I'm picking up
reports of more attacks in other cities
it's a fight they won I say let's give
it to him
[Music]
Target mark
time to create peace bullets
[Music]
the world is coating on us
foreign
[Music]
just as the Phantom thieves have helped
never forget that we're a United Force
who can rely on each other
used to be grateful to have been made my
subjects but you're just a matterless
little brother
unfortunately returning will be no easy
feat
somewhere deep inside I know you realize
things can't go on like this
so will you take a stand beside us yeah
let's show them what we got
[Applause]
[Music]
play it day one with Game Pass
and
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
huh
yeah
there's got to be a way out of this
Johnny
I'm dying
there's nothing can stop that
yeah
[Music]
my name is salbert
I'm an nus intelligence analyst I know
about the bomb ticket in your head
and I can save your life
what's the catch
I need you to get to Dogtown
residents
president managed to crash her space
Force One into our humble District man's
got a thousand and one reasons to want
Myers as a hostage sleeper agents
time to wake them up
so nusa is tossing us back into The Fray
huh stay sharp we're in the wolf stand
now
get Myers out of there
time to eat back
her safety is the top priority
[__] they catch us out here we're dead
wait hear that
this way
ratted us up you know the treason ain't
every black and white
it's a charade V wherever she goes
people get hurt bodies drop just one
word Songbird promised me
The Cure
the situation has changed you need to
know if you're with me illusion of
Freedom draws in the desperate Pick Your
Truth be come on got iron in your head
you've got to put it to someone's head
pull the trigger
oh
do anything and do it soon I'll die
[Music]
foreign
people don't like you very much do they
sent here to the living lands
by an improve who couldn't bother to
come himself
to investigate some plague
that seems to be corrupting of their
souls
trust you
but the truth is
you scare us
the way the way fight
the power you will
sits you keep
you're either here to save us
or destroy us
[Music]
now that you have all this power
what are you gonna do with it
[Music]
play it day one with Game Pass